[Musique]
bonjour ils vont pas qui tu es bien
bonjour merci aux auditeurs des
médiateurs aussi puisqu'on est sur eux
et sur le net donc on nous regarde aussi
on nous écoute et on nous regarde
ils vont pas quitte donc venez que votre
double casquette de président du conseil
d'administration du centre hospitalier
universitaire de la martinique et de la
régie eau d'ici là la régie de
distribution d'eau courante
alors on va commencer par là vous venez
avec une bonne nouvelle vous avez signé
il ya quelques heures hier soir un
protocole d'accord de fin de conflit
avec le syndicat cgtm soem que contient
ce protocole d'accord ils vont pas
quitte alors si vous voulez après
plusieurs semaines d'une bonne semaine
un petit peu plus et des échanges avant
le plutôt difficile et tendue nous avons
pu quand même éviter que le public ait à
subir les préjudices liés à une coupure
d'eau et par conséquent et en fin de
soirée nous avons pu converger vers le
protocole d'accord on me dit protocole
de fin de conflit et par vaux école à le
risque n'est ce pas décollé à 12h30 à
dire que contient ce protocole d'accord
qu'avez-vous concédé aux syndicats alors
vous voulez contient pas de gaulle
d'accord il ya des concessions
réciproques
il y avait quatre points trois points
essentiels sur la plateforme au point
concernant le directeur général qui a
été écarté puisqu'il était question
qu'il
bolden se pose c'est pas le directeur
général qui est écartée c'est le point
de revendication point de vue légal de
corps évidemment j'aurais pu groupe est
presque comprendre le contraire donc ce
point de revendication a été bien
évidemment le tracker général restant
parce qu'il n'y avait aucune raison on
espère qu'il abandonne son passé tout à
chacun c'est un coup d'arrêt aux
connaître qui l'a fait comme à son
travail qu'il n'y avait rien à lui
reprocher le deuxième point concerne des
élections professionnelles bep l'arn à
trouver quand même d'accord y'a pas le
problème le point central de ce
mouvement concerne comme vous le savez
des mesures disciplinaires ont été
prises
vos dix agents n'est ce pas convaincu de
mesures disciplinaires
le licenciement cette mesure
disciplinaire ma femme et moi c'est
pourquoi c'est l'occasion de bien précis
serait assez la mesure extrêmement en
l'occurrence la wii c'est le dernier
niveau
ouais la mesure 10 et d'une mesure
disciplinaire codifié dans le code du
travail c'est à lui que chef
d'entreprise privée je dis bien privé
parce que pour les fonctionnaires
c'est une autre procédure un chef
d'entreprise qui a connaissance et ce
fut le cas bros dc puisque nous avons
lancé une enquête administrative sud un
allèle venant de l'extérieur et cette
enquête administrative nous a permis
d'identifier des faits très graves et
sérieux pour reprendre le terme voire
juridique et des locaux directeur
général avec des preuves
ah oui avec des preuves flagrantes
irréfutable que nous avons présentées
aux autres locaux général a connaissance
de faits de ce niveau de gravité sa
responsabilité pénale de didier pénale
est en cause s'il ne prouve à
disposition dans les deux mois qui
suivent
n'est ce pas la connaissance de ces
faits c'est ce qu'il a fait il l'a donc
comme le prévoit le code du travail
jeudi le code du travail
il a donc organisé un conseil de
discipline
je rappelle que conseil de discipline et
paritaire ad autant aux besoins du
personnel que des représentants de la
direction
six personnes toi toi et ce conseil de
discipline à 7 voix contre 6 n'est ce
pas c'est à godet sur la gravité des
fautes qui était reproché à ces agents
est bien évidemment et dont
amezis team à savoir la révocation la
révocation le titre évocation les
licenciements en tout cas où ce contrat
alors vous rappeler que c'est des
contrats de pour de priver le droit
privé d'accord dites moi mais pourquoi
parce que le syndicat a demandé un peu
l'inversé disait mais attendons que la
justice qu'au pénal les personnes soient
effectivement au moins mis en examen
peut-être pas attendre qu'il soit
reconnu coupable éventuellement par par
un tribunal mais pourquoi ne pas
attendre au moins des mises en examen
avant de de procéder à ces sanctions
extrêmes ce qu'on leur a expliqué c'est
qu'il s'agit là de procédure totalement
disjointes la pause et du pénal c'est
une chose c'est codifiée par le code de
procédure pénale c'est extérieur et les
mesures disciplinaires sont codifiés
dans le code du travail
le directeur s'était tenue de penser
difficile avec la pluie cette décision
le même se montait à lui-même sur la
situation s'appelle oissel d'infraction
ça a dit qu'il serait perçu comme
russell sadique il a connaissance de
faits graves il ne fait rien donc c'est
le code du travail qui paie si cela n'a
rien à voir avec la possible perte c'est
l'occasion d'ailleurs de préciser que de
leur entreprise plus de 95 booth à des
mesures disciplinaires ne sont pas
nécessairement suivie d'une plainte au
pénal la plainte au pénal
on exige une espèce de mélange de porter
plainte vous êtes porté plainte relative
les nominativement maintenant cette
enquête contre x
voilà on a aussi une petite évolution
allons-y alors nous avait déjà vous
porter plainte contre x qu'on ne voulait
pas véritablement identifier toutes les
personnes concernées donc vous porter
plainte contre x
ça vous permet d'ouvrir la procédure là
nous avons quitté j'appelle le
licenciement ou en montagne c'est pas
hier et donc nous avons continué la
quête il l'enquêté a permis d'identifier
très précisément les agents concernés
les salariés concernés
et là nous sommes en situation cette
semaine de porter plainte nominativement
avec constitution de partie civile ce
n'est pas obligatoire sur quel est ce
que vous reprochez enfin des plein de
portes sur ce que voulaient mentionné
avant la prise illégale d'intérêts non
ce que ça donc s
dix régions il ya une espèce de faute
grave dans la gestion des marchés
publics des attributions irrégulière de
marchés publics à cette entreprise je ne
vais pas dire davantage
parce que prêtait été déposé en fait ça
peut s'appeler en terme simple
détournement de fonds publics c'est ça
le thème donc là qu'on veut comme vous
identifier sa des entreprises vous êtes
tenu enfin le directeur général est tenu
de mon double est mes beauty plein
compte déjà précisément et indiqué il
faut avoir mené une enquête beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus précis c'est ce qu'il
a fait en quelques mots vraiment vous
pensez que la situation s'apaise qu' il
ya plus de menaces de grève et le
possible interruption argovie 19 quand
même plus de quinze jours que nous
échangeons sur ces questions là avec
l'organisation syndicale et bien
évidemment nous avons signé un protocole
de fin de conflit
sa porte bien son nom donc aujourd'hui
le confie sur ces questions là est donc
terminée il n'y a pas de raison que
l'audition et au venir de la faire elle
même elle n'est pas terminée et je suis
à l'on continuera de au sein de
l'entreprise selon le code du travail
l'affairé est terminée puisque les
décisions ont été prises bien évidemment
comme plainte est déposée au niveau du
domaine pénal
donc l'affairé suivant son goût hélas
nous ne maîtrisons ni le mode opératoire
ni les délais ni le calendrier le climat
doit être un peu particulier quand même
un depuis quelques temps à rouge comme
elle a un goût de nous deux qui s'en
allait seul crime
le climat n'est pas gelé j'ai eu
l'occasion de le briser
audi compte 260 âge sur les 260 agents
et on a un peu moins d'une dizaine qui
ont participé au mouvement
c'est vous dire qu'il ya une très large
unanimité a beau décision rapidement ils
vont pas quittes pour terminer donc le
collectif chum souvent du vent et
l'association sauvez la santé en
martinique ont rendez vous demain c'est
demain
de sèze metz demain au ministère de la
santé alors bon pour essayer d'obtenir
50 millions d'euros pour l'hôpital de la
trésorerie afin d'abord et avant tout
payer les fournisseurs mais aussi
d'investir vous n'êtes pas à paris vous
président du conseil d'administration de
l'oph une unification que j'ai les
accompagnent est-ce que je les avait
accompagnés au mois de novembre
bon des raisons évidentes n'espère m'ont
retenu mois tenu ici mais en fait je
partage tout à fait là la démarche et
j'ai j'accompagne la démarche même à 10
ans puisqu'il ya deux doubles denis
votre problème
alors allez marin l'a tout d'abord des
préoccupations de très court terme c'est
à dire qu'il faut que l'hôpital
fonctionne au quotidien et pour cela il
faut payer les fournisseurs mais il faut
se rappeler la loi de la trésorerie de
l'argent qu'est sinon les fournisseurs
livrent pas les lundis kamal voulu c'est
une jos pour régler les problèmes au
quotidien c'est déjà l'urgence depuis
longtemps au salon bien évidemment il
faut un dommage aux professionnels de
santé qui véritablement se sont
mobilisés pour que les prestations
apportées n'est ce pas au patient soit
de qualité
mais enfin nous arrivons à la limite de
ce qu'ils peuvent faire
donc aujourd'hui pour être fournis je
répétais c'est de l'argent qu'est-ce
vous véritablement s'approvisionner pour
fonctionner au quotidien
et puis je n'aurai pas le temps de
l'évoquer mais a les problèmes ce qui se
situe dans le plus long terme concerne
l'équilibré général l'équilibré
économique du ch et de là bâti nous y
reviendrons nous viendrons en ram en un
mot vous êtes optimiste que le ministère
va va lâcher alors je ne peux pas disant
que la question est tellement sensible
puisque je rappelle que la santé est une
compétence de l'état et on comprendrait
mal que l'état ne fasse pas à séoul et
le nécessaire pour permettre au chu de
fonctionner et de répondre aux attentes
légitimes de la population c'est une
obligation incontournable pour vous pour
l'état absolument
merci vont pas quitte à avoir répondu à
nos questions bonne journée et mais
c'est à moi de vous remercier
[Musique]